it's time for my favorite part of the
week your wife no no it's the why it's
the white leave your entry close my
voice is a little lab it's gone it's not
good not good at all
I can make weird noises that I can sound
like a dying fox
I guess not like big I don't think this
is helping I should stop let's get in to
the memes I'm so excited my parents
reaction after giving birth to me why
does it look like that relatable yeah
why does it look like that I don't get
it why is it so ugly can we put it back
please put it back please don't want
this one ugly poor Fox I came a fox in
Minecraft
very cute chuckles I mean D hey stop
stop this this is so offensive and rude
okay just cuz I have a pet doesn't mean
it's gonna go bye-bye I have plenty of
pets that it's fine Sven is practically
immortal okay let's get real here okay
this looks important attention
nine-year-olds we need to get beautified
200 mil before August 31st why oh I know
this Oh YouTube is changing their system
so that it will not update subs live so
you can't check a live feed we can still
hit 100 million subs we just won't see
the crossing of it I think I don't know
how it will work but this means we have
a deadline August 31st baby we got a hit
under minced herbs easy that's easy no
problem
another beam beep I can't understand
this is hard
oh yeah I try to go on the subreddit I'm
like oh cool like helpful tips for
Minecraft what kind of stuff are they
gonna tell me like it would be really
helpful and then this is it this is it
just means I don't understand and it's
kind of mean it's not a meme it's a mean
we're always there 9999 million so that
is Brock
bricky blub I didn't swore I said
fracking YouTube but fracking that was
our in there or I'm making it worse for
myself
you can ah we're an end game boys
100 million can you madam what's gonna
happen at 100 million nothing livestream
that's right 12 hour livestream at the
hundred million in minecraft take
frequent breaks when I get tired I get
it completely Valerius it's gonna be the
most incomprehensible stream of all time
an ordinary Pig Pig save them
baby Papa I understand this one that's a
good meme I understood I must have the
biggest brain of all remember when PT
pipe laid the walking dead and
complained that telltale was killing off
too many characters and adding new ones
too quickly
yeah that is this serious come on DJ cow
is how to let replace about all the og
people are still there spenders there
you're getting this their what their
sheep they're in our hearts they're in
our hearts
they're inside us the last thing Jurgen
saw before his day stop stop
I understand this and I do not like this
I do not like at all village speaks more
Japanese than Swedish in his videos now
I just had the Swedish accent what does
she want
Swede Jean this we need to download all
fake tips like we did with endgame
spoilers and egg why can't we Oh what if
I point there
that's a Frick I present to you the
Battle of wizard and peepee poo-poo army
as they hold me and peepee poo-poo hoo
hoo peepee poo-poo forever we're still
gonna defeat the Ender Dragon sorry that
there's no microvidia I have a bit of a
technical issues with it and I've been
busy
it will come in a couple days I know
it's delayed it just so
you know I am aware it just short on
time right now why are we still here
just to suffer one thing I realize I'm
actually really good at recreating the
the laughs from that meme I can't do it
could my voices ruin but otherwise it's
like you can't tell them apart
[Music]
I've been practicing my I think
something's saying now two of the most
iconic towers in history why is there a
penis next to Ikea Tower swipe next on
that one thank you just bought the
Minecraft last week I'm 60 I love the
game so far Oh everyone knows
six-year-olds can't have fun so this is
it really good news we done it gamers
we've done it this smile face whoa yeah
what her sheep please give us ring give
us justice give it back out you may now
kiss your husband now freak you are so
busted
oh that's so sweet look ma he built the
Frick chick yeah I still understand this
one okay look what my mate saw at the
Lego store near meme template Pete if I
should sleep in the nether so he can see
the really cool Easter egg yeah whoever
patches together is definitely going to
the range I was so good can we get an
epic round of applause to dr. Phil for
hosting me review and doing a great job
Felix if Sven dice oh no which will
never happen it's many mortal
I gave him my own blood Felix a blue
creeper so cool minecraft veterans
that's cuz you're cowards I'm a bike
minecraft veteran as well and I knew I'm
new and our Zach
and not afraid of you mr. blue people
poo almost made an oopsie I have to
sleep I mean put involuntary servants
it would surprise to me if someone made
a story out of that we're like I was
watching a Tom Holland video now it's
been revealed in the background I just
realized click that away yes yes I
watched Tom Holland compilation videos
yes I've been exposed it's getting late
let's meet again tomorrow
Hey thank you a key vote you never know
when he's gonna strike at night at dawn
at day once you hear get in the boat you
best get in the boat
you can press f3 and B to show hitboxes
so you won't hit Swinburne break in the
boat I know about this I still fail so I
just use the lead Thank You them that's
an apple tip actually I appreciate it
looks like you're cheating when you do
it though and I never cheat in any game
ever in my life so before Felix I built
some stuff oh that's adorable and I love
it
- pp-people looking hella sexy is it me
OOP we're looking like more like a PP
where the Frick did Banks nametag go
Felix please explain please please I
need eggs they'll hear us
oh my God look now that is adorable I'm
not logged in Rolf is there everyone is
there is Doofenshmirtz it's so popular
they made him into a real thing
what is that top I don't understand you
and your memes oh my god stop 24 year I
guess I have to watch this now 24 year
old Vanessa the millisecond that Ferb
turns 18 what do you get it now I don't
sad Dinnerbone noises everyone is here
yes Felix everyone Dinnerbone sound
Oconee the sky I don't remember I
remember leaving him somewhere I just
don't remember where I'll find him still
my favorite band theory about all a
brief that oh yea cuz I love burritos I
is actually golden and blue that is
perfect that's how it's supposed to be
nothing rhymes with bigger every right I
have this habit of rhyming everything
now and then I'm doing live streams and
I'm just like nothing there's just no
words baby foxes enjoying a beautiful
life with their mother Felix look at me
I am your mother now my boyfriend and I
watch pigs all the time together but
recently he's unable to because he
joined the Marines and wanted to share
this boots I'm leaving for marine corpse
basic this is the last video I'm gonna
see for 13 weeks I've been a
nine-year-old for a long-ass time I'm
gonna miss you keeps trying safe for me
oh god the pressure I will I will you
stay safe as well isn't this the first
episode of yeah yep and this came out in
yep and then I came out in 2017
so therefore Pierce clearly copy guy
makes sense to me so stop falsely
harassing jacksFilms Jack copy painting
play yet so for those of you who for
some reason don't know this because I
feel like it needs to be addressed
jacksFilms has a serious cold yeah he
did it way before me but then my series
was so similar to his that I thought it
would be funny to rip it off completely
and call it love why instead of
yesterday I asked you it's last week I
asked you they're completely different
shows at this point like there's really
no similarities except the family
direction I suppose but some people
still have it in their idea because
they're dumb ball of ball
they think that Jack actually copied me
which is really annoying and really
stupid and I'm sorry Jack I'm sorry
domain name PT PI uploads a new video
it's not minecraft dr. Phil is house
they may review noise twice found this
texture pack online what are this bunch
of ducks I don't like it I don't like
this one wha when side says he'll bring
back the tuber simulator mean if we make
good memes about him haha
sob is bribing I like it well played
yeah
when Felix through is flat and far but
it came back I'm separately is it
possible that he doesn't come back it
hasn't happened yet but I'm always so
nervous when I flick it off in the
distance beauty pie lights creeper head
fireworks I saw somebody comments about
that I'm sorry can we just stop and let
peers know how grateful I think we are
for his consistency over the years we
love your peers thank you for your
smiles 900 thanks guys
you know I I've uploaded more than just
four days in a row right the thing is
like I don't work ahead I really unless
I'm forced to do it I don't do it
because I I don't like losing the
defining direction like with the
minecraft server for example it would be
a lot easier if I just shot that ahead
but then I would miss like your guys
feedback and all that stuff and I want
to do it together so I appreciate that
you guys appreciate it basically is what
I'm saying the royal wedding the actual
royal wedding thank you very much what
is that what is this I don't want to see
this anymore views before YouTube stop
piers give banked a totem of undying Oh
does that work that's smart
yeah I know this I mean I did it with
the sword and I thought that was cool
but don't worry my pets never dies I
won't need this don't worry about it
hey Pierce here's some interesting stuff
my creepers okay charge papers don't
make bigger explosion but more damage oh
don't just make bigger explosion okay if
your creeper gets killed by a skeleton
or straight it can drop a music days I
know about this I just haven't been able
to do it you can wear mob head to lower
the detection rate oh hi mark it doesn't
work all the time but it's still really
useful sadly you cannot get player heads
and survival without commands the only
mom said will drop them are oh okay okay
oh man well how do I get creeper heads
dead oh I can okay I really want to
creeper head minecraft
proving kids wrong once again thank you
for doing this if an alien captured
Marcia and implanted an alien baby
inside her would you raise it as your
own honestly depends how ugly it is what
if it's a slime ball I can't love a
[Laughter]
sleaze oh god I realized I have to bring
it all through to the ender dragon
because I made a promise I made a
promise goddammit and I intend to keep
it
friends don't lie I'm not good at making
the funny meme but I can't drop well
damn you can that's dope got the merch
in everything very epic upload finish
and herb memes trigger red Nader don't
make me say that word ever again every
time spin gets damaged attention Felix
be very careful around these two mobs
they can apply extremely annoying debug
way makes your brain go so small go
small it it's better for you to keep
this since to save your brain from
street yeah I think that's pretty
accurate Church of what they're sheep I
feel like I've seen this but I don't
know if it's been on the wire and it's
goddamn amazing I love it Swedish fans
like the tower 2019 color
sorry PT paiement yoga in 2016 we are
why are we talking about it you guys are
so busted
I'm telling mom okay I understand since
Felix doesn't know anything about
Phineas and Ferb he doesn't understand
why these images can make us
nine-year-old so uncomfortable no you're
right this looks completely normal
absolutely what a great cartoon it looks
so well drawn Felix kills Council of
water sheep's friend council kills Felix
friend
oh my god I don't believe it right
before the end pitifully after the end
we're gonna defeat the Ender Dragon the
final boss of Minecraft creepy oh and
Rafa and Rufus no face I'm the dumbest
man alive ender dragon is immune to
arrows you're clearly dumber but I said
that petition for Felix to name the Tree
of Life
Burlison that's good I like that
stop saying Sven is gay he freaked
Virgin Turtles girlfriend which makes
him bisexual you can freak out a
principal you can freak to show someone
that you are not afraid of them okay
also let me remind you span is a dog in
Minecraft just a reclaiming the boys
thing is sleep sleep sleep sleep
it's a wallpaper Oh Felix to fix your
meatball you can change your grass the
grass patch so we look like brown sauce
brown sauce brown shoes brown sauce what
I thought of in the last episode of
Minecraft baked plus fire aspect to
Firefox oh that's cool man Felix a that
he can't use the boot to defeat the
Ender Dragon his sub ready just you wait
you little cowards your little frickin
Fricks
I will frickin frickin crack here
protect the attack but most importantly
he nap
I know this sounds crazy I would love to
keep going but I have to go and play
more minecraft reaching hundred million
to beat t-series reaching hundred
million for a 12-hour Minecraft
livestream less freaking get it gamers
check out the Merc that's not the merch
I have it somewhere support the channel
we have such cool epic merchants we also
finally really released for the last
time the zero def merch and the 80
million club copy the strike edition
limited time thank you guys for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow on the next
episode of Minecraft
Haeju gosh well you haven't tried to per
symbol a turd since me after 50 million
outros much just go it's still relevant
just download it